[Música]
muito prazer de estar aqui com vocês eu
tô aqui pra conjugar com vocês
a magia de ensinar me tocou muito o que
aquele professor americano falou porque
ensinar é realmente uma magia
principalmente num país onde a educação
não funciona eu não estou vendo aqui
o país ocupa uma das últimas posições na
educação do mundo em 70 países nós somos
o 68 e como você vai explicar isso num
país que gasta 5 por cento do pib
educação que está acontecendo que faz
décadas que nós nos saímos desse desse
vergonhoso vergonhoso é dados
então você tem 30% dos alunos não
alcança um nível adequado de português
você tem 14% dos alunos que não há ao
consuni nível adequado de matemática e
os alunos que não aprendem 55% são esses
alunos que são meu foco e 55% eles são
20 milhões de crianças brasileiras
zerada se na escola que são as crianças
que eu recebo no projeto erê onde você
tem que construir todos os circuitos
neuronais onde uma coisa é uma coisa
outra coisa é outra coisa eu sempre me
perguntando criança de 10 anos nove anos
cinco anos na escola que não não
consegue falar não consegue se comunicar
não conseguem aprender e eu dediquei a
minha vida a essas crianças e dediquei e
dedico esse é um menino que foi abusado
aos seis anos de idade então como você
vai uma criança dessas sua morgen ti
amor
daí o sentido de que ali naquele lugar
tem alguém que entende ele vai amar ele
que vai fazer com que ele perca o medo
e é isso que nós fazemos todos os dias
no projeto heleno
[Música]
josé isaias mais uma banda de rock então
conversão várias vezes sentava agora ele
fica bem graças a deus
jean
essa é uma classe que eu tinha de
crianças todas elas com problemas
cognitivos
elas eram adorava isso mas isso demandou
muito estudo da minha parte para
entender acho que fazer com que elas se
desenvolvesse um espaço não tão grande
de tempo porque uma reabilitação
cognitiva leve de seis meses a um ano e
até hoje estudo quer reduzir esse tempo
eu acho que a gente pode fazer isso se
deve fazer isso e essa aqui foi há uns
20 dias atrás uma menina que chegou a
uma família completamente desestruturada
e que eu vou ter que começar a fazer
todo esse processo
enquanto os dedinhos tem aqui quanto os
detidos técnico cho quantos do título
aqui muito bem para ver a que a tia não
tem pressa
até aqui foi muito bem
parabéns agora eu quero que você tem um
monte de bater muito bem de novo
bom então esse é um trabalho que eu faço
com as crianças eu mesmo estão em sala
de aula
mas isso é um trabalho de aceleração né
até que esses circuitos neuronais as
sinapses sejam construídas para que ela
possa participar realmente de uma sala
de aula e começar o seu aprendizado e
nós temos no brasil infelizmente em 2016
um milhão de crianças saem da escola ano
passado no rio de janeiro foram 18 mil
onde estão essas crianças que estão
fazendo nós vemos muitas delas nas ruas
já entrando na marginalidade então como
eu disse tem alguma coisa errada na
escola brasileira e por que não se
aprende tempo motivo primordial para mim
que a violência do estado de uma
violência ímpar na porta da minha escola
no complexo da maré na zona norte do rio
ano passado foram 159 detidos
nós estamos em dezembro esse ano foi um
pouco menos foi 124 mas vocês podem
imaginar você ensinar crianças contínuos
como se fosse uma guerra da síria mas é
isso que acontece
e todas as comunidades pobres
brasileiras debaixo de desonerar de
risco é uma guerra é uma guerra
eu não vejo não vejo sinceramente nenhum
governante tomar consciência disso fazer
alguma coisa pra que isso cesse o que
impulsionou para continuar um pouco da
minha história em cinco minutos e enfim
é 71 anos de vida não 50 anos de dessa
história
bom tem trechos é duas fases na vida
três fases na vida que mudaram
completamente o meu destino
o primeiro foi quando eu fui voluntária
e fui para crianças cegas quando tinha
13 anos e isso todas as famílias
deveriam fazer mandar seus filhos fazer
um trabalho voluntário para conhecer uma
outra realidade com esses aí do seu
conforto do seu caso no e ver como é que
a vida das outras pessoas
a segunda foi contundente na
universidade muito cedo com 17 anos eu
fiz o projeto rondon que pra quem não
sabe é um projeto é do governo federal
que mandava estudantes pra mim com joão
gekko do brasil eu fui pro ceará e no
ceará
eu vi a pobreza mas a pobreza braba que
eu não conhecia no rio de janeiro
olhando aquelas crianças barriga grande
com fome eu disse que nem mesmo é isso
que eu vou fazer não importa qual seja a
minha profissão que eu não sabia ainda
eu vou dar uma atenção essas crianças e
conseguir uma bolsa para estudar na
frança foi catar estudar filologia e
linguística onde o fez graduação e
doutorado e eu continuei a trabalhar com
os filhos de imigrantes na periferia do
pares e pares e conseguido uma ong
estrangeira um estipêndio e eu fui
pesquisar as crianças em países em
guerra na áfrica etiópia sudão é ele
estréia tanzânia e depois angola e aí eu
comecei a formatar tudo um conhecimento
que iria aparecer bastante depois quando
eu fundei o projeto
o eln e quando voltei ao brasil em 1980
e foi trabalhar nas ruas
eu vou dizer uma coisa vocês eu amei
trabalhar nas ruas
eu amava cada uma dessas crianças como
se elas fossem minhas
eu ia todos os dias eu fundei uma escola
sem portas nem janelas
eu tinha um prazer estar com elas de amá
las
se na elas de mostrar um outro mundo
dessas crianças completamente renegados
nesse país completamente né eu não
conseguia que aquelas crianças fossem
vistas em 1993 um dos meu grupo c no
grupo que ficava lá candelária e esse
grupo da candelária e 18 foram
assassinados por policiais militares
eu todo dia dava um toque maps botarem
no telefone ligado estava tudo bem no
doping norma de 72 crianças e o dia os
policiais militares foram assassinados
eles me ligaram tinha tanta gente peguei
meu carro e fui foi a primeira a chegar
nessa posição dessa foto fiquei de meia
noite e meia até seis da manhã em santo
e que eu pensava com eles
abraçados comigo que os outros corpos no
chão eu dizer que a corda e acolhe o que
você vai fazer e agora eu disse agora eu
tenho que fazer
de repente eu tenho que fazer muitas
coisas e naquele momento eu decidi por
causa de um desses meninos que disse que
tinha um parente debaixo de um viaduto
em uma favela eu decidi a brincar abrir
a primeira sala de aula doer e debaixo
do viaduto
de repente tinha 200 crianças comigo na
e nós construímos um espaço com tapume
enfim uma coisa muito precária e ali
debaixo desse viaduto fiquei quatro anos
até 1998 quando eu fundei o projeto erê
aí o meu sonho porque quando estava com
aquelas crianças na rua pensava meu deus
eu tenho que ter uma escola possa
continuar dessa maneira e aí o sonho
aconteceu por um empresário americano
que me ligou vi uma reportagem não sei o
que você precisa é se uma casa e aquela
favelinha foi transferida para o
complexo da maré e eu segui aquelas
crianças do complexo da maré onde estou
até hoje há 20 anos né
sendo assim eu comecei a formatar uma
pedagogia de ensino que a pedagogia o e
melo que é focada na memória
aqui já foi falado mais ou menos o que é
memória memória e imaginação
a associação imaginação sentidos que
mantém a memória viva porque crianças
estressadas crianças traumatizadas
elas não têm a memória curta trabalhada
por isso que elas não armazendo e é por
isso que dizem ah não aprende é burra
crianças traumatizadas tem inteligência
intacta
o que a gente tem que fazer saber
trabalhar essa inteligência ou todas as
inteligências e sala de aula e eu
comecei a estudar na neurociência na
educação porque depois a partir dos 190
já tinha e o meu objetivo qual é
equilibrado os dois hemisférios
hemisfério lúdico aprendi a cantar
dançar tudo bem
o hemisfério esquerdo titã os
compartimentos do conhecimento e se é
fechado então um dia a dia o dia a dia
da equipe é abrir essas caixinhas todos
os dias para que elas consigam ter uma
mola que feche que abre quando
necessário que é a nossa memória o que
trabalhar em sala de aula estímulo
visual retórica oralidade exercício açor
acho que você só aprende com a realidade
você não aprende escrevendo descrição e
análise velocidade cerebral inteligência
espacial inteligência interpessoal
emocional linguagem linguagem porque
porque eu como filólogo e sei que uma
criança de seis anos precisa ter quatro
mil palavras da memória longa para poder
aprender a ler e escrever
olha as crianças chichico pra mim tem
300 400 daí porque o brasil não
alfabetizada crianças e três anos quando
a maioria do mundo em um ano nós somos
fantásticos raciocínio lógico
memória curta e longa agilidade mental
plasticidade cerebral coordenação foco
pré conhecimento e à curiosidade que se
contrapõe à monotonia porque as crianças
não gosta da escola é chato prender eu
não gosto de estudar porque tem a
monotonia né e ensinar a emoção
ensinar é amor amor de que ensina e amor
de quem está aprendendo então essa troca
ninguém vence
não tem e não tem como nessa troca vai
funcionar e os objetivos foi é otimizar
o tempo que a amazon maior armazenamento
melhorar a qualidade do aprendizado
aumentar a velocidade cerebral etc
aí o sonho continua porque em 1901 2018
e nós estamos agora são 15 mil
professores capacitados na pedagogia
érico de melo de 1 199 escolas no brasil
que utiliza uma pedagogia e em 2015
aconteceu o sonho maior
a unicef reconheceu o projeto irei à
pedagogia ou uma das seis melhores
estratégias para crianças onde há lixo
aí abre um mundo é porque eu tenho
capacitar professores na europa e em
escolas que lidam com refugiados
então esse é o sonho de toda a educadora
esse é o sonho de ver a sua metodologia
o que você estudou o que você fez
tornar-se política pública como foi no
rio de janeiro como foi esse vídeo e do
marajó várias cidades do brasil que
utilizam essa pedagogia com sucesso
cerca de 95 por cento de sucesso
desbloqueio de crianças traumatizadas e
o que eu queria deixar aqui bem claro é
que tudo é possível
não há nada que não seja possível em
educação
eu tenho de verde de propósito porque eu
vim aqui dizer pra vocês que a esperança
é que vai melhorar no brasil nós temos
ter esperanças temos que ter fé
nós temos que ter confiança nós temos
que fazer a nossa parte ou como
voluntário nos seus estudos não importa
nós temos que ter conosco aquela vontade
de melhorar nosso país eo nosso e também
o dos outros porque o mundo todo está
uma grande confusão não é e isso só é
possível
amigos como amor amor pela humanidade e
amor por uma criança amor porém foi por
tudo que acontece nesse mundo né
eu queria terminar pedindo a vocês e
vocês disserem comigo assim bem alto
minhoto para que fosse ouvido nos quatro
cantos do mundo
a educação só a educação muda o mundo
vamos lá só a educação muda o mundo mais
alto
só a educação muda o mundo
[Aplausos]
[Música]